أجنبي
إبراهيموفيتش ، أسطورة اللعبة السويدية
لعبت للعديد من الضاربين الكبار في أوروبا
إيه سي ميلانينتا أي إكس برشلونة باريس سان جيرمان
يوفنتوس والرجل الذي توحد بعمر 41 عامًا
قد يقول البعض أن مسيرته المشهورة ستقترب
من نهايتها لكنه
منحني شيئًا مختلفًا تمامًا  أجب عندما
جلست معه مؤخرًا ، استمع
إليه طالما يمكنني الحصول على نتائج ،
سأستمر في اللعب في اليوم الذي أبطأت فيه ،
أريد أن يكون الأشخاص من حولي
صادقين ويقولون إنه يتباطأ وبعد ذلك
سأكون واقعيًا و  أقول ، ثم انتهيت
ولكن هذا ليس الآن هذا ما
تخبرني به أنه ليس الآن نحن لسنا
هناك حتى الآن
أعتقد هذا الموسم نحن العديد من
الفرق في المقدمة التي تقاتل من
أجل  المركز الأول ولكن علينا
فقط الاستمرار في الفوز في الألعاب
استمر في اللعب بالطريقة التي نقوم بها
وأن ننمو لنصبح أفضل ونحقق
حقًا
ما فعلناه العام الماضي وأن
نكرر البطولة حتى يكون ذلك
رائعًا وأعتقد أن  العقلية
موجودة ونحن نعلم  ما يتعين علينا القيام به
للوصول إلى المركز الأول لأننا
فعلنا ذلك العام الماضي ، لذلك كان علينا فقط أن نعمل
بجد ونؤمن بتاريخ
ميلان الفخور في
دوري أبطال أوروبا ، وكان آخر فوز للفريق على الرغم من أنه كان
عام 2007. هل هذا إلى حد ما  أظهر
كم هم بعيدون عن وتيرتهم في هذه
المرحلة
ولكن علينا أن نكون واقعيين هنا
قبل عامين هذا الموضوع ميلان أعني أن 95
من اللاعبين لم يلعبوا دوري الأبطال
وفريقي هو فريق شاب ،
فهذه هي السنة الثانية في أوروبا.  بالنسبة
لهم وفزنا للتو بالبطولة في
إيطاليا ، لذا فهو فريق متنامٍ ومن
الواضح أننا نريد أن نقدم أداءً جيدًا في
أوروبا ومع تاريخ النادي نريد
أن نطابق ذلك في الأوقات الحالية